I just get this weird like gaggy  sensation I know it sounds weird I do  throw up before every game and like I'm  a creature of habit I'm slightly  superstitious I might not be  superstitious but I'm a little stitches  as soon as we get done with our free  game I run inside I put my helmet by my  locker room it's just like all right I  gotta get something up going to my  rookie year is it the rookie or second  year I finally I just like you know what  I'm just gonna try it I threw up in that  game I was like I didn't have any of  those symptoms I was like you know what  like I'm just gonna have to start doing  this from now on and I've got some guys  that usually throw up in in the room  with me sometimes they're there  sometimes they're not everybody exactly  yeah can you throw up right now that  would be great for raiding no it  probably could no